ja wir machen ja heute so einen kleinen
jahresrückblick und mein verlierer des
jahres ist liebe cdu die konnte dir das
eigentlich versammelt das jahr begann so
gut eine neue ein neuer cdu-chef wurde
gewählt armin laschet mit der münze
seines papas in der hand konnte doch
eigentlich alles nur noch gut gehen die
umfragewerte lang im märz sogar bei 38
prozent doch dann der streit um die
spitzenkandidatur mit markus söder und
als man sich dann einige lieber armin
laschet gefühl im rücken das war leider
kein rücken stärken sondern ich fürchte
das war ein messer da hinten drin es
folgte ein wahlkampf unter friendly fire
und wobei von kampf kann man gar nicht
sprechen es war eine schlafwagen tour
mit den halter stopps leider von einem
fettnäpfchen zum nächsten dabei das
lachen in der flut oder mein
persönliches highlight der 20 beglückte
dackel monster das war ein absolutes
highlight aber das war aus meiner sicht
verzeihliche fehler unverzeihlich waren
momente wie man geht focus mikrofon
vorbei und kann nicht mal drei punkte
aufzählen wo für die eigene partei
eigentlich noch steht und da möchte ich
sagen lieber konservativen das war nicht
nur der feder von armin laschet sondern
das war der fehler der ganzen partei
dass man nicht mehr sagen konnte wofür
man steht und wofür man eigentlich noch
gewählt werden sollte es folgte eine
schlussoffensive mit dem ruf rot rot
grün muss verhindert werden den sind
auch einige gefolgt die antwort leider
nur wahr wir wählen die fdp und auch
dieser fehler der wäre vermeidbar
gewesen aber ja bis zuletzt habe ich
noch wirklich geglaubt es wird sich
ausgehen wird abstand war so groß wird
sich einfach auf stimmt ja hat nicht
geklappt aber jetzt heute das große
happy end die parteibasis hat endlich
ihren liebling wieder märz ist es
geworden mit dem glanz von zwei
niederlagen wird der 66-jährige nun die
konservativen in eine glorreiche zukunft
führen man möchte leise
aber liebe konservativen habt ihr
eigentlich uns schon die antwort gegeben
wozu man konservativ ist jetzt noch
braucht was eure antworten sind für das
aktuelle ich glaube da ist noch eine
antwort schuldig
sebastian ich glaube erst mal wirklich
vorstellen das will ich künftig mit sind
simultanübersetzer wir sind mit
untertiteln versehen die meisten
zuschauer im nördlichen nördlich von
main werde nicht wissen was du meinst
wird sich noch ausgehen
dass österreichischen heißt es wird noch
funktionieren das wird nun klappen aber
ich sag dir ganz ehrlich ich glaube es
ist ganz gut dass die cdu diesen dämpfer
bekommen hat ich glaube das wird er ganz
gut tun jetzt meine position zu sein die
cdu hat sich unter unter merkel in eine
zentristische partei entwickelt die im
grunde das sozialdemokratische in sich
vereint hat und die wissen selber nicht
mehr wofür sie stehen ist eine gewisse
chance dass jetzt mit friedrich merz
wieder so ein bisschen mehr
konservative in die die identität dieser
parteien kommt wenn ich mehr oder links
die jüngsten auftritte von merz anschaue
muss ich sagen habe ich da wenig
hoffnung denn ich habe mir angeschaut
bei den kollegen im zdf gestern hier
sich wie er sich an daniel cohn bendit
angewandt hat und auch mit körpersprache
kurz gedacht geht zum traualtar danach
zusammen ich glaube ich glaube friedrich
merz hat inzwischen so viel kreide
gefressen und hat ein image berater der
im ständig sagt er soll nicht so
arrogant wirken er soll gewinn wenig
freundlich sein dass er ständig lachend
durch die welten aber du sagst lassen
durch die welt ist aber eher ein grund
er ist in den umfragewerten in den
vergangenen monaten immer weiter runter
gerastet bilder hätte er so weiter
machen können und einfach sagen können
mir egal die basis steht hinter mir und
ich stehe da jetzt und ich werde schon
noch beliebt oder brauche genau das was
ich dann kurz jedenfalls der mit einer
kante kommt der idee halten
dafür so altena die frage natürlich ist
er ist ja entsteht dafür etwas finden
wie viele konservative wende der cdu ja
ich finde es interessanter alexander das
duo sebastian kurz erwähnt weil das ist
ja wirklich ein ganz tolles beispiel
jenseits von seinem skandalen und so
aber neben ihnen einfach mal als
politische figur als erfolgswelle figur
jenseits von dem wir es vielleicht
erreicht hat aber und seiner
ausstrahlung er hatte etwas sehr verein
vereinen das auch da sich und eine sehr
klare politische jahr kontur also erhält
eine scharfe konservative konto aber
gleichzeitig etwas sanftes im auftreten
der wurden alle umarmt hat aber ein
klares politisches profil bei märz war
es anders der hat eine diesen klares
persönliches profil auch und ein klares
politisches profil gehabt und die cdu
muss aufpassen dass sie mit ihm nicht in
so eine partei des herrn witzes wieder
fällt denn seine region wo er herkommt
der sauerland dieses dieses westfalen da
ticken die uhren noch ein bisschen
anders als in berlin mitte und ist so
jemand noch parat wenn du so lange in
der politik warst du warst 20 vor 20
jahren drin dann schaust du das immer an
und denkst die märker die kannst nicht
irgendwann komme ich wieder dann
verliere ich zwei mal und dann bin ich
da zum dritten mal wird da noch jetzt
jemand sein der ihm sagen kann mensch
friedrich macht das aber anders weil
sonst wirst du nicht belegt einfachen
grund ist das nicht also ich finde das
ein gutes team in sicherheit zum
beispiel mario czaja das ist für mich
ganz klar ein großer hoffnungsträger der
union und ich muss noch eine sache zu
sehen was dann kurz sagen wenn er immer
so gefeiert würden irgendwie mit profil
konservativ bedeutet ja nicht
populistisch zu sein oder rechts zu
reden wie sebastian kurz sebastian kurz
ist für mich ein populist wie er standen
teilweise mit ihm gesagt wir nehmen gar
keinen flüchtlingen auf ich finde was
konservativ ist muss wirklich mal wieder
neu begründet werden weil ich habe das
gefühl konservativ wird heutzutage
gleichgesetzt mit schafen rechten
aussagen das war ja auch ein bisschen
das profil von sebastian kurz und ich
glaube dass das team themann kuban hat
man heute gesehen an der seite philipp
antwort man heute gesehen mit märz
auf die
schätze die arbeit da mal rein weil das
ist einfach die menschen beraten ja
nicht friedrich merz gesagt so doch
gesammelt haben um ihn herum und legt
nahe dass die im grunde im grunde ihn
auch bereits im märz hat vielleicht ein
zwei leute auf die erhört ansonsten
glaubt er glaubst du mal wieder gibt es
jemanden gehört ich glaub ich schon weil
weil zumindest temporär sonst würden wir
nicht solche auswirkungen sehen die
alexander angesprochen hat nicht das war
ja wirklich sehr alter sind noch in
europa sprach ja und seine gestik
hat sich verändert ich finde er wirkt
über beraten am ende ja das wäre aber
neue war bis vor ein paar wochen hat er
dennoch keinen pr berater habe ich
erfahren hatte ein aber der hat sich
zumindest nicht so durch so bürgerblick
30 und hat eigentlich sagen wollte weil
ich fühle mich gerade mist verstand ich
meinte mitberaten mario czaja was ich
sagen wollte mit dem mit dem dem satz
dass die um den ruf standen ob jemand
bahn ist natürlich seine berater aber
ist zeigt ist jemand aus der älteren
generation wie friedrich merz bei den
jungen ankommt und ich finde das ist zum
beispiel ein ganz großes zeichen dafür
dass friedrich merz die partei
vielleicht wieder nach oben bringen ich
finde das war vor allem aspekt besonders
spannend dass man jetzt auch friedrich
merz selbst weil wenn du dir die polit
umfragen also eine gesamtbevölkerung
anschaut ist es ja so dass er meistens
auf den letzten plätzen liegen dass in
der beliebtheit wirklich wahnsinnig
schlecht dasteht und eigentlich hat man
in der union ja gerade mit armin laschet
die erfahrung gemacht den hat man
trotzdem gewählt obwohl seine umfragen
katastrophal waren und jetzt unabhängig
von der frage ob erschafft sozusagen die
cdu wieder zu einen oder einen neuen
kurs zu schaffen war schon schwer genug
ist muss es ja auch schaffen als person
dort zu stehen als zugpferd der es
schafft dass die menschen wieder die cdu
will grauwal dieser drei kandidaten
zeigt auch den desolaten zustand der cdu
ich musste sagen wer wer traut den unter
uns wirklich norbert röttgen zu die cdu
zu führen helge braun als etwa bei aller
liebe aber den als als anderswo aber
märz ehrlich gesagt aber wir konnten ja
nicht verhindern dann habe ich
aufgeschaut hat zeigt doch wie
ausgelaugt diese partnerschaft braucht
sie erst mit generation damit sogar mit
turban und tadija fantastische blicke
ich in berlin im leben in allem ist der
linkeste von petra pau gehalten
wahlkreise das direktmandat eine
therapie ab dafür musste er nur gregor
gysi umarmen glaube
die diese generation märz da gibt es
einfach niemanden ich glaube in der wahl
zwischen pest und cholera zwischen
braunrot warum erst im märz schlecht
alexander ist nicht schlecht aber er
steht doch nun wirklich nicht für den
aufbruch der cdu dass sein kandidat der
mehrfach gescheitert ist der ist eine
partei gescheitert aber die anwender
haben
herrchen in der ecke der totalen
beliebigkeit sich dank für gar nichts
mehr sie war ausgehöhlt nach 16 jahren
angela merkel die aber noch alles
verbunden hat und in dem moment als sie
weg war war sehr viel das wird ein hobby
in sich zusammen ist wo man luft rein wo
man reiste und in sich zusammen und märz
muss natürlich jetzt erst mal das
konservative profil der cdu wieder
erwecken damit man irgendetwas hat womit
man erkennbar ist und dann können die
anderen leute drumherum vielleicht an
anbauen aber guido westerwelle gott hab
ihn selig hatte nach dem absturz der fdp
damals gesagt wir müssen mal wieder was
ins fenster stellen und das ist so